الحمامات البيئيه عباره عن مشروع ما
بيحتاج لا مي طبعا للفلاش ما بيحتاج صيانه
ما فيه ريحه نهائي ما بيحتاج اي نوع من
الكيميكال كيماويات وما في داعي ما بيعمل
اي نوع من السلاج او الشغلات السائله
والمنتج الاخير بيطلع من التواليت هو
عباره عن سائل سماد طبيعي ف جميع الاملاح
المفيده للزراعه العضويه بستخدم معه اللي
هي البكتيريا وخلط بالماي مثل مثل الخميره
يعني تقريبا بعدين برش الواحد هي مره بس
بالشهر كل دقيقه هي البكتيريا بتتكثر
بتعمل كولوني كبير وبتاكل كل الشغلات
العضويه الصلبه يعني ما في داعي اي نوع من
المنتس السائل هو بس اللي بيبقى بروح لتحت
لجوا على الخزان خصوصي لاله ومن من ورا
ممكن نجمعه ونخلطه ب مي ونحطه على
الزرق الدراي تالت او نون فلاش تالت
موجوده من زمان لكن ما في شيء
كان نافع 100 م يعني يا اما لازم انه بده
متنس او بدها مساحه كبيره او رائحه ممكن
نستخدمها في اي مكان الاندور حتى بالمنازل
اذا عندك ديزاستر ل كوارث طبيعيه شح
المياه مشكله عويصه بالعالم
يعني لازم لازم يكون عننا وعي لانه اذا ما
قدرنا نعمل شيء اليوم اولادنا اولاد
اولادنا ما راح يقدروا يعيشوا على على
المنوال اللي نحن عايشين
عليه